hello and welcome to this video Nia's
its opponent and the new one never
played him well sloth I should really
learn the slowest laughs this is all the
rage nowadays they are all playing okay
are you ever not so well known line when
she takes 25 I sticking with the night
so interesting uh-huh hmm okay giving
this more of a Greenfeld flavor
yeah I was worried actually if this
should be six as a move that leads like
that looks like it leads to more more
trades not so nice maybe I can no queen
bee three okay and ants give me the
bishop pair please he doesn't want to
take why play Bishop g4 mm-hmm okay and
he just want to take Wow we should a
three and black resigns or what's the
plan maybe that was a slip he wanted to
go e six where resides is a bit much
sorry but you will lose the exchange
Joe 97 not much else okay if I take yes
to take with the Queen much should be
useful so they have to win with the
exchange yeah not something that happens
automatically so how to do that I also
happen on an extra pawn in the center so
I'm trying to do something with it hope
you can take f7 now and I will
definitely do that black resigns yeah
short win not very exciting but if I
stop to upload those then it yeah I get
picky about the games that I'm taking
forever during court stuff yeah I think
here Black is fine I I think white
should be a little bit better better
center and the two bishops but he's okay
if he plays something like a six for
example this kind of setup is some I
think well known giving up the light
squared Bishop and then we are setting
all on light squares very difficult to
break down this is the kind of setup
that for example garter come scheme has
played very often and defended with
success yeah I think this is hmm
questionable it's not necessary to take
and now I'm I guess that was some kind
of some kind of slip if you go E six um
I think whites advantageous parable I
mean it's it's not nice let's say will
be one night no wants to cover this
layer here
and now yeah roop do you want a normal
move the engine suggests age for this is
actually interesting move getting age
five in is useful here to weaken blacks
kingside and age five weakens a bit
computer wants to go here form well yeah
white is better him it doesn't make much
sense to take on c3 actually if you set
up with e6 it's better to not take that
fields fields better more solid okay
short game but easy points for me thanks
for watching